[Music]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen please rise to
welcome the Dean faculty and students of
Columbia University's School of
International and public affairs
[Music]
you
distinguished faculty and staff proud
family and friends an honored guests
welcome to Columbia University and to
the graduation ceremony for the School
of International and public affairs
[Applause]
today we are delighted to confer degrees
upon the great and unbelievably
energetic class of 2019
[Applause]
I'm Cory Wade the associate dean for
student affairs and adjunct professor
here at the school and as dean of
students it is my absolute pleasure to
welcome you and to celebrate with you
the achievements of the remarkable women
and men who sit before us this evening
some of the students graduating today
may remember that during orientation not
so long ago I shared that cephas mission
states that the school quote serves the
global public interest by educating
students to serve and to lead graduates
we know that you will do just that as
you leave Columbia we are confident that
you will apply what you've learned here
to serve and to lead and to make your
communities your countries and your
world all better places we also hope
that you will stay in touch with us here
at SEPA you are and always will be part
of our family and we hope that you will
come and say hello if you happen to be
in your second home in Morningside
Heights we'd love to celebrate your
achievements and learn what you do over
the course of the years ahead now it is
my privilege to introduce Cephas Dean
Merritt e/j now a former lawyer and
trade negotiator Dean Jana was a
globally renowned expert in
international trade and investment since
becoming Dean she has pursued innovative
programming and central banking
development practice urban policy and
technology among many many other areas
please join me in welcoming Dean Merritt
EJ now
[Applause]
Thank You Dean way good afternoon
graduates faculty friends family members
as dean of the faculty it is my great
privilege to welcome you to see past
2019 commencement we're delighted to
have this afternoon of joy celebration
and achievement we start by recognizing
friends and family including those who
have traveled such a great distance to
be with us it's their love and guidance
and support that has made this day's
journey possible for our graduates so I
invite our graduates please join me in
thanking your friends and family who
have no greater joy than being here with
your success and achievement and
thinking of your well-being please join
me in thanking
[Applause]
thank you I'd also like to extend a
special welcome to the dignitaries and
leaders who are joining us today
including President Paul Kagame of
Rwanda and members of the kaga my family
I also deeply welcome our commencement
speaker High Commissioner Michelle
Bachelet former President of Chile whose
remarks we look forward to you know it's
often said that graduation is both an
ending and a beginning
it's an ending because it marks the
culmination of our graduates period of
stay at SEPA and Colombia and I think
you will agree it's a time that passes
very quickly and it's a beginning
because today is the next chapter of
your lives and careers and the purpose
that you will shape in the days ahead
we hope that this has been a
transformational educational experience
and that you feel or will come to feel
that SEPA has better equipped you with
the tools the knowledge and the
perspective to thrive in a changing
world a world filled with potential and
uncertainty
today you are 800 in and two in number
from some 78 countries amazing and I
hope
[Music]
[Applause]
it's my hope that you have become
advocates for rigorous evidence-based
analysis a global perspective informed
by national factors but also committed
to understanding the approaches of
others and that your ideas have been
tested and broadened in a changing world
those elements are important and our
mission includes thinking about problems
and solutions and policy responses at
all levels and along many different
dimensions whether it's improving
governance of cities or countries or
companies finding and expanding
multilateral regional national
approaches in a world of growing
skepticism of anything but solutions
that are homegrown improving conditions
on the planet
stabilizing economies supporting
economic growth eliminating poverty
addressing humanitarian crises reducing
conflict managing geopolitical tension
for SEPA these are just a few areas that
we study deeply and engage and we invite
you to double down on these problems at
this moment the work of SEPA the work
that you will do is only more relevant
in the world today and graduates we are
convinced that we need your creativity
we need your passion we need your
ingenuity and we know that you will go
on to achieve remarkable things we are
grateful to have had you in our
classroom and contributing to the
vitality of our intellectual community
you will always have a home here and be
part of this community so let me say on
behalf of all of our faculty we are very
proud of you and we extend to you our
deepest congratulations
[Applause]
it's now my pleasure to turn to one of
the important traditions of SEPA which
is to recognize some outstanding
graduates and faculty who are the
recipients of some of our distinguished
awards this academic year if I may have
your forbearance from clapping too much
until the end of my introductions but I
do invite the awardees to stand as I
announce their names and awards we start
with the Harvey picker prize for public
service and recognized jazz neat hora
for his exceptional contributions
[Applause]
we have a few more let us also recognize
Rafael Smith Thank You Rafael Smith
Memorial Prize nagura is shimmied anova
Sierra Robbins
[Applause]
Ciara Robbins for their essays that will
soon be published in SEPA news and for
the dr. Susan Aurelia gitelson award for
human values in international affairs we
have a number of recipients hurrah
Azhar Leah giddons Wang Yong Rashid
acaba Jacob sprang and Gillian tIMCO for
a remarkable workshop project on
assessing the impact of women's village
Savings and Loan associations on
building resilience in humanitarian
response and for the lay-up airy award
for progressive sustainability we also
have a number of recipients for a
workshop project energy resilience in
Puerto Rico the role of advanced micro
grids and I'd like to recognize rippin
Shia bandsaw ceylon Chen grace
Cushman sháá dude hey koti Sheng
Alejandra Vasquez and Jacque way Walla
and for the CAA Campbell Award in
recognition of Bill Campbell former
chair emeritus University trustee and
CAA co-founder for her extraordinary
contributions to student life at SEPA
and service and her dedicated leadership
as a student leader her spirit of
collaboration and partnership with
fellow students faculty and staff I'd
like to recognize Joanna Kyle C possible
and this year we have a new prize for
data analytics for public policy that
recognizes the most creative rigorous
and insightful empirical project or
paper by SEPA students and for their
research project on perceptions of
governance the epic effect in
sub-saharan Africa the recipients Daniel
a hello
jonathan from our san calling city and
mingie june so congratulations to all of
those students for their many
achievements and now I'd like to
recognize two faculty members who've
been honored by the students this year
for outstanding teaching for small
course James HULC for the course writing
and delivering speeches for politics
private sector and nonprofits and for a
large course Deborah MacLean for the
course corporate corporate finance
[Applause]
congratulations and now it is my
distinct privilege to introduce our
commencement speaker United Nations High
Commissioner Michelle Bachelet she
embodies strands of cephas intellectual
priorities from her leadership on human
rights and humanitarian policy to our
long-standing history and connections to
the United Nations which go back to our
founding in 1946 as well as our deep
committee commitment to governance and
the study of security and our deep
expertise and ongoing study and focus on
Latin America and in particular Chile
High Commissioner bascially assumed her
role as UN High Commissioner for Human
Rights in September 2018 and as I as
High Commissioner she serves as the
principal Human Rights official of the
United Nations and spearheads the UN
Human Rights efforts around the world
prior to this important role she served
as president of Chile on two occasions
from 2006 to 2010 and from 2014 to 2018
she was the first female president of
Chile and a longtime human rights
champion and really a groundbreaking
leader in many ways she's a pediatrician
who began her government career as an
advisor in the Ministry of Health she
became the first woman to lead Chile's
health ministry in in 2000 and its
defence ministry in 2002 she became
involved in human rights activism in the
early 1970s she and her family were
political prisoners after her release
Madame bascially and her mother spent
several years in exile and returned in
Chile in 1979 finishing school and
becoming a pediatrician and public
health advocate she has undertaken many
significant extraordinary roles over the
course of her remarkable career serving
as the first un woman
of the partnership for maternal newborn
and child health chair of the social
protection floor Advisory Group and
other leadership roles in international
organizations we are deeply grateful
that she traveled to SEPA from Geneva to
be with us today and take time to share
her ideas with us please join me in
welcoming UN High Commissioner for Human
Rights
thank you Thank You Dean Indiana
distinguished members of the faculty
dear graduates and Families it's really
an honor to be speaking at this joyful
occasion we are here to celebrate your
skills and knowledge as a pass you pause
at the opening of a new chapter of your
life we celebrate the bonds that you
have shaped the path that you are
preparing to take chopped and I will
tell us life may be compared to a piece
of embroidery of which during the first
half of his life immense is the right
side and during the second half of his
life the wrong the wrong side is not so
pretty as the right side but it's more
instructive because it shows the way in
which the threads have been worked
together
of course he meant a person not
specifically a man but you see the point
as you look backwards once you have
enough perspective in the random choices
and accidents that pull your life in one
or another direction
there were also patterns and turning
points points were if you had not turned
you would have become a very different
kind of person the Dean was mentioning
some aspects of my history and I want to
make sure as well because to try to make
the point that you'll understand a
little bit later when I was 24 I had to
flee my country my father who had been
detained and tortured died in prison my
mother and I had also been detained my
fellow Chileans were being abducted and
fourth disappeared
killed and abused by the military
dictatorship which has sales power my
studies were interrupted I had no idea
how long I would be gone for four years
I improvised everything was unexpected
and not always in a good way
I went to Australia then to Germany
learning new languages and continuing my
medical training I know what it is to
feel anger fear those moment when hope
drains away and this
flood scene when I was 28 I returned to
my country with a child and a great
yearning to contribute to the country I
had longed for
I earned my medical degree and work with
an NGO which gave support to children
whose parents had been killed
disappeared torture or in prison each of
the children have been harmed in some
way or many ways because men in power
almost all the authority at the time
were men had chosen for this to be so in
every street were families living in the
economic misery and pain created by
abuses of authority so I learned to set
aside my anger and to replace it with an
approach focus on dialogue on finding a
common group of understanding in which
we could begin to resolve the divisions
between both camps democracies was
regain in 1990 the dictatorship
retreated and Chileans grew more
demanding and more fearless more
involving new networks which press for
greater rights and freedoms there was a
tremendous surge of intellectual
energies cultural social political I
became as you heard Chile's Minister of
Health in 2000 the first women that's
post and then the Minister of Defense in
2002 and the first woman in the Americas
to do so and the fifth in the world and
that doesn't mean that I was fantastic
it means that how bad women were in the
world at the time so I became a minister
of defence in a country that was still
fractured by the dictatorship so we set
up and strengthened other processes for
reconciliation and accountability as
well as empowering women in the armed
forces and Chile was able and has been
able to build sound democratic
institutions which ensure justice
political economic and social stability
and poverty reduction it has continued
to build up the trust of the people
fostering cooperation between the States
and its citizens which is the only
sustainable way to ensure progress for
everyone this was and is an immense
process the great transform attic
dialogue of solutions which has involved
many people and I'm
honored to have serving it my two men
they test my country's present world
tremendous opportunity to contribute I
feel the same about my work at you and
women and now as the UN High
Commissioner for Human Rights and today
I speak as high commission of a human
right but also as a pediatrician as a
former president and minister as
somebody very much worse in military
affairs as a feminist and as a mother
and grandmother when I prepare to enter
the adult world I could not have
predicted any of this and I'm telling
this story because I know you too will
face an immensity of choices and as you
prepare to open this new chapter of your
lives
you may be feeling burdened by the need
to define your life's purpose your goals
and that legendary dream you keep being
told you should be living and that is a
very challenging quest I cannot offer
you a key that unlocks a safe and planet
next level experience my life has been
as you have heard much more messy and
turbulent but yours will be too but I
can tell you that in times of crisis
when the future is worried and there
don't seem to be many good options
you will find that core values will
ground you so don't so that no matter
how unpredictable the winds you will
know that the past you shaped through
life will be one with integrity so allow
me to suggest what those principles may
be because I'm sure you share them
whatever you brought to this university
you have certainly learned that no
matter how deeply you examine one topic
in international relations that effort
will always feel incomplete because each
topic and each country is connected to
so many others we're not alone or other
people matter justice matters violence
exploitation discrimination and
injustice have far-reaching consequences
by trying to see matters with full
clarity and understand others point of
view by acting with integrity to advance
justice and human rights
by seeking always to build on your love
for other people and all forms of life
by looking to construct and advance
rather than to destroy you will be
taping a life for yourself that holds
steady to your principles and I look at
this class of young people fluent in
public policy and international
relations trying the multiple
disciplines with a focus on the
different point of views viewpoints
which make up our multifaceted world I
see how you have learnt two brief theory
and practice and the broad and deep
knowledge you have put together from so
many sources of perspectives and reform
the world around us is very jittery and
fearful now the pace of technological
change and environmental destruction is
quickening human beings are breaking our
planet catastrophic climate change
declining biodiversity mass extinctions
plastic polluted oceans aren't urgent
threats and the motivation of world
leaders to constructively and jointly
address these issues is flagging so we
need you in a very real sense it is up
to you your generation will face the
full force of this failure to act or as
I am convinced can be done you will turn
the tide and shape a new consensus to
resolve these problems because money is
no excuse the cost of human rights
action or climate action is really very
little compared to the terrible
destruction and cost of inaction so we
have a path to solve the problems of
climate change and growing conflicts we
have the 2030 agenda which has been
fully negotiated by every state in the
world which can eradicate extreme
poverty and inequality including far
more people in the benefits of
development the Paris agreement set out
the terms for the commitments undertaken
by all states to focus action and
mitigation and they have the potential
for real impact all of these measures
rely on support for human dignity
equality and human rights the right to
life liberty and security of person the
right to education health food
their clothing and social security
freedom from any form of discrimination
whether based on sex race belief sexual
orientation or any other factor freedom
of expression and the right to privacy
freedom of thought conscience and
religion freedom from torture and from
unlawful or arbitrary arrest or
detention the right to a fair trial
these and other fundamental rights and
freedoms are the elements that build
resilient societies which are able to
withstand and surmount threats
peacefully resolve disputes and
facilitate sustained progress in
prosperity and well-being for all their
members and you know this is true
because it has been true in your own
lives those of you who have benefit from
life in peaceful and sustainably
prepares society are living in countries
where people's right are being upheld it
is the principles of human rights the
bill more stable more peaceful and more
adaptable societies with dialogue
cooperation and respect
there are detail guy through the
unpredictable challenges of future
events whether they involve
transformation of the digital landscape
or the prospect of violence human rights
principle and law have been constructed
to protect humanity from danger so in
this celebration of your achievements as
you look forward to what is to come
I suggest you live with your
great-grandchildren in mind you cannot
know who those children will be where
they will leave what will they will look
like even the languages that will speak
you cannot know how many great and great
great grandchildren you would have but
you can work for all of them for their
well-being their freedom their
sustainability of their environment and
for the right as human being to live in
equality and dignity thank you and great
success
[Applause]
thank you so very much hi commissioner
bascially for those very important words
and perspective it's been our privilege
to have you with us it's now my pleasure
to introduce Kirsten MO heesun chair of
the CEPA Alumni Association to introduce
our c+ president and offer a few words
[Applause]
thank you Miss bascially and Dean J now
it is my great pleasure to be here today
with the extraordinary class of 2019 to
congratulate all of you and welcome you
as Cephas newest alumni while graduation
celebrates the completion of your degree
it also marks the beginning of your new
engagement with the world beyond SEPA
your SEPA education has equipped you
with much of the knowledge and many of
the skills necessary for success but
whatever your objectives ultimately will
be up to each of you to achieve your
goals I am pleased to tell you that
Sita's alumni community will help your
SEPA degree entitles you to membership
in a unique network of more than 20,000
alumni in over 153 countries all of them
united by their shared experience and
the desire to make the world a better
place as the chair of the CEPA Alumni
Association I welcome all of you to this
vibrant and diverse community and
encourage you to stay connected with
each other and with SEPA with this in
mind the CEPA Alumni Association is
pleased to present each of you with a
graduation gift which we available at
the reception immediately following the
ceremony we hope that this memento will
evoke fond memories of your time at SEPA
and will remind you to stay in touch
keep us updated with your contact
information and any exciting or personal
or professional developments that you
wish to share the CEPA alumni community
is eager to know you and to help you so
please stay involve
with SEPA and play an active role in the
alumni association connects with fellow
SEPA graduates around the world or in
the online alumni community volunteer
your time and insights with current and
admitted students come back to campus
for the annual alumni day and reunion
dinner celebrate with us at the Global
Leadership Awards Gala and join us for
informed discussions and networking at
Columbia and SEPA alumni events around
the world most importantly as you embark
upon your newest journeys always
remember why it was that you chose Seba
and the remarkable faculty and staff who
helped guide you the outstanding
students who challenged and inspired you
and the loving family and friends who
stood behind you on behalf of the Alumni
Association and SEPA alumni throughout
the world welcome to our distinguished
community and congratulations again on
your extraordinary accomplishment
it is now my privilege to introduce our
next speaker Joanna Kyle who served as
president of si pasa and is also the
recipient of the Columbia Alumni
Association's prestigious Campbell Award
Joanna a lieutenant in the u.s. Navy
graduates today with the master of
international affairs degree and a
concentration in international security
policy please join me now in welcoming
Joanna to the podium and to cephas
alumni
[Applause]
I love you too
good evening I thank you Ohio
Commissioner bascially Dean Jana and
Kirsten for your introduction I know
we're all gonna miss the game of Thrones
finale to be here tonight but there's
nowhere else I'd rather be shadows on
the wall noises down the hall life
doesn't frighten me at all these are the
opening words to a Maya Angelou poem I
stumbled upon a few weeks ago downtown
and a museum shop the Vashon Michelle
basky exhibit this children's poem
titled life doesn't frighten me at all
was illustrated with Vasquez art the
intersection of Angelou who grew up in
my own home state of Arkansas and Basia
a phenomenal young New York artist of
Haitian in Puerto Rican descent struck
me and stuck with me as did this poem
bad dogs barking loud big ghosts in a
cloud life doesn't frighten me at all we
don't talk about fear not often and
usually not here at Seba as future world
leaders in order for us to do our jobs
to the best of our ability we have to
address fear name it and reframe our
conversation around it in facing our
fear making fear a servant rather than a
master of our actions we exhibit true
courage and there's a lot of power in
these moments and getting to know all of
you in the past two years I've learned
just a fraction of the fears you've
faced I know you moved to the United
States not knowing any English piecing
things together from harsh school
experiences and a lot of post-it notes
until you made your way to this
University I know you came to school
even on the days when you didn't think
you could
plagued by anxiety depression or
post-traumatic stress disorder I know
you kept coming in the midst of loss I
know you weren't even sure if you could
keep coming to see pop
because finances weren't what you
expected them to be and that you worked
and hustled far more than anyone should
have to to be here today I know you've
stood up for yourself your classmates
and future iterations of students
regardless of the repercussions by
advocating for issues important to our
class diversity need-based aid
assistantships and the Graduate Workers
Union I know you stared down your fear
of rejection of failure of your own mind
and body to be here today and so have I
the tassel I'm wearing is one I had the
opportunity to wear exactly seven years
ago today at the commencement for my
undergraduate institution the LGBT
community and my college had given me
this colorful rainbow tassel to wear for
graduation I never wore it
I was afraid afraid to be rejected by
folks I cared about afraid to be honest
with myself and everyone else but I
brought that tassel with me everywhere I
moved from Washington DC to Japan and
here to New York and today I'm wearing
my tassel not because I'm not frightened
at all but because it's more important
to face fear and to have courage
together we can follow my Angela's
advice on facing our fears in life by
taking action
I go boom make them shoe I make fun way
they run I won't cry so they fly I just
smile they go wild let's continue to
make them go wild together as a
community our opportunities to face our
fears don't end today and our chosen
work will be confronted with difficult
policy choices as High Commissioner
bascially mentioned we can't we can go
along with the status quo or we can face
our own fears as we make and support the
policy that creates a better world for
the disenfranchised may we continue to
support one another in
facing our fears and living our most
courageous lives to create policies and
lead in the only way we know how with
courage because life doesn't frighten us
at all
[Applause]
[Music]
Thank You Kirsten emoji sent for your
leadership of the CEPA Alumni
Association Thank You Joanna for your
wonderful leadership of Tsubasa
and for your great words and now we turn
to the beginning of the graduation
service itself and we will have each of
our faculty leaders read off the names
of each program and we start with dr.
John mutter director of the PhD in
sustainable development and the deans
will introduce themselves thereafter
after John
[Applause]
so I have the best job at sea but
without doubt the very best job in fact
I rarely think of it as a job I think of
it as pleasure I get to work with some
of the smartest people that exist on
earth some of the people who were the
most dedicated to changing the world in
a productive way I get to nurture I get
to encourage I get to guide these
wonderful people and I'm now going to
introduce five of them to you in order
in order of height no alphabetical order
I'm going to read their names the title
of their dissertation I will resist
reciting their dissertation although I
know them all by heart
and I'm going to tell you the places
where they have going to point words but
before I do that I want to acknowledge
the placement director for this year
professor Christian also Tiki pop they
all benefited from Kiki's guidance and
we're very very grateful Thank You Kiki
so first mady been attire and illusive
the seat title of each dissertation is
clearing the air essays on the economics
of air pollution he'll become an
economist at the International Monetary
Fund
[Applause]
Denis Duque essays on using climate
information for disaster and climate
risk management she'll become a postdoc
at the London School of Economics
[Applause]
Timothy Forman essays on the economics
of environmental change he will become a
postdoc at the european institute on
economics and the environment
[Applause]
and before I introduce the next person I
will tell you that II just a few hours
ago stood at this very podium and gave
the student speech the student
presentation at the GSA s convocation
okay this is Jason Chun you Wang his
dissertation is on essays on over
aviation and sustainable development he
will first be a postdoc at LSE and then
take an assistant professor position at
Occidental College
[Applause]
so we have five graduates and I have
five children so I have known I've
learned a long time ago not to have
favorites but the title of the next
person's dissertation is my favorite so
this is Alice Shambo Chang is Zhang
sorry
when nature meets human nature essays on
the social impact of energy
infrastructure and environmental policy
she'll first become a postdoc at
Princeton and then an assistant
professor at Washington and Lee
[Applause]
congratulations to you all I am urbano
Garza I'm in the senior assistant dean
for student affairs at SEPA and I will
now read the names for the candidates
for the Master of Public Administration
Rebecca
Abramson Fatima noir Aftab and she
tagged our Wow
[Applause]
maja T a GU babidi Elmas aqueon
Raul al-qaeda Alonzo Aisha I mean stable
uncle
Blanca are his Mandi Maria Fernanda
Avila Reese Janna Bay June ban crippen
jaya Bansal victoria barb Anouk and we
will bury Ataris scott building Brian
Bell
[Applause]
alia Bhatt eeeh Davi Bonilla a sailboat
I ever Claire Breedlove Lucia Brizzi Oh
below
[Applause]
Jordan Burke
yulik I see turns out
[Applause]
radius out Alberto Kirino Mariela hor
say Andrew Cheng
[Music]
[Applause]
jinke chang-sun Jung Chang Jing Tian
Shen Chiayi Chen Yong Shi Rutan Zealand
Shan Zhen Shan
[Applause]
Tiffany Chang John choy Katie choy and
race chunky Torres repulsive Harry
[Applause]
Anthony Supriya and Christian
Achillas Chrysostomos Julia Chung
[Applause]
[Music]
ah di Nicola James full heart Ling song
[Applause]
Larisa Conant Edward Teddy Corcoran
crazy its way Catalina they meet Chuck
[Applause]
Sowmya devil maria jose diaz marquis de
la plata shreya digs
[Applause]
Raghuveer dina ba hey Tanya carried on
ma died and on TNT and on Molly dough
Michael Drake sha do
sure you do Dexter Dugan yowee Matthew
acre Jacqueline Aang
Rocio Espinosa de los Montero's
Hernandez Alvina fan-xiu Anton in s
Fernandez Alonzo Flores
[Music]
Diego forlán dodgy you young go far in
fact
gaffar for hinga VAR we are Givens
[Applause]
Gabriela Ginsburg Fletcher
Alicia gareki Sanjana gareki
I'm sorry Sanjay Nagar t na nuggets
that's day Jacob Ross who is long gone
[Applause]
Jackson wall chain-link wall Olivia
Camille has Fernando a Dodge motor
Gino jon hamm chichi her gents in hell
Sanna hey Olivia hefferman Carl Henn ler
Carla Veronica Enriquez
[Applause]
Evan Hill Matthew Henson land Juan de
LAN Hui
Kirsten Holland just need hora yanti
whoo whoo Jia Wang ping Jung Hwan
Matthew Hughes Elena mere le and Akane
kcon Anika I Badou knee Nasir Ibrahim
[Applause]
Ricardo yeska Julia Embry aku hamsa
Nasim Iqbal Sameer Jagdish giu Marshall
ji
[Applause]
my wands young Shalaka Joshi Gregory -
here Joey
[Applause]
Nadia kanji Leon Kaplan Mayan Karen
at the Sun all Rahman Khan
ibrahim ali khan german co co John Kim
Michelle Kim
[Applause]
Alexandra of top ski Omer could be Kevin
Lane
[Applause]
Rachel Lee
Jamie Lee hae young me Elena Leggett
ocaña leg Anandi Javier león Clarissa
Liang
[Applause]
[Music]
young Julie yo golly Shri long Lee Shin
jolly mangly Janet Lee Shao Lin
[Applause]
[Music]
butchering Lin's
Audrey Litvak seashell new single ooh yi
Fei Liu Yun Chu Lu Zhi Cheng Liu
rosemary Lozano mantilla Joseph lo j
Weimer Ranma Jessica Marcos and a
Markowitz a real a Martin
[Applause]
Indira Desiree Martinez
Kamiya Tommaso mascara a limit alone
[Applause]
Yara matter Carlos Mateus amaura
Lawrence McDonald Jenna ela Moreau
[Music]
Hironobu Mita
[Applause]
hilarya Moraga
Alberto Morales
[Applause]
dynamo sabasha it's a goddamn around
Jessica Murphy Kate Murray
Natasha Nair
[Music]
Mohammed Salim Nasir Chitra Nasrudin
brandy dueño valiant Oh Chinese ogle an
Ellen basic as a long glass so Kelsey or
[Music]
yes Ron de Juan Francisco Pacheco
Flanagan Giovanni began Bella's
lamping better ping odd Ringo fajita
[Music]
[Applause]
Eric Besnard Polina Plata stood upon our
I've met now hey Zhanna malgorzata
Resnick Martine dreidel materiality King
wrong
Victoria Rodriguez stuti Sachdeva
[Applause]
the be her Saleem Edwin Saliba Chandana
Sajjad arecia Salman Martin Santos
[Applause]
Lakshmi saravana Bhavan Chloe sack nerve
the mini satisha
[Applause]
Christopher Sherman Jacob shaman
Emma Scott obvious error metallo's shoe
high shall look Sherman Bingley and she
saw Ozzy Dickie
[Applause]
Darin single Monica song Hashmi shed
zi Han Seong Priyanka sunny Sarah stone
[Music]
Katelyn Schroeder coyote Suzuki Katie
Swartz Mariana tazuna
[Music]
babe eight an econ town Raytown marked a
news Dominic Tao clear title man a reit
attacker nithya zero Gillian timko Shu
Han tomorrow
Eugene sang Steven Tubman
[Applause]
Loreena or bina
Alejandro Valdez thermo Deville sukirti
been a yoke Lee upon Matthews
[Applause]
[Music]
Maggie Wang Yahoo one more wrong one
shut you Wang Hao Wang glory one judge
wrong
Lily way
Landry Doyle wheeze Valerie butts Annie
Sloan Woods Wyatt
Dominic Warner Jeremy Worthington Xin
Mei Wu Yu Tong Wu
yah yah yah yah Cathleen see a yellow
true coming in Stella young super yang
yes you yang Tao you Yao Lin cien Peggy
Lee Doogie young missing you
mark you UJ 1 yen you on Lucia's an RD
[Applause]
in Osaka bhava and she Rohtang Cindy
Jang me she Jan jacket yang
you Chang you are yin Zhao Shi jeans out
seeing hands out in Liang chow
so this is the end of the NPA and as you
can hear Google doctor dr. Glenn ting
[Applause]
[Music]
good evening my name is Glendenning
it's its - great - great pleasure to
present the unstoppable and sometimes
rowdy class of 2019 graduates of the MPA
and development practice the MD peace
Daniel aho song
urn on
[Music]
[Applause]
Maria despina a guru
Fernando Armendariz cuenta
[Music]
[Applause]
Ryan ballad louder Barrera Vera
Jennifer Bradshaw Grayson Coldwell
Louise
Rita Contino Thomas de Mayo
Corey fain Bianca
Flamengo chigau Rika gosh
[Applause]
[Music]
Natasha go L poor v gu l Zachary Hansen
[Applause]
[Music]
Lindsay Patricia horn nagura he Samedi
Nova Sara Johnson now Shere Khan grace
duck he on Kim
Amelia Rose Knutson today's emoni ki
bong gay lung Gaza Jonathan
chimera sin' Justine Lavoie
[Applause]
Lee even Samira Luka mwah
nitin majima
[Applause]
Caroline McAfee
[Music]
rakita mayor atre shreya Morelli Raveena
Putney caught Claudine Patrika Gigi
[Applause]
Tyler John will occur
[Music]
Osman Majid Rana Eric Regalado Martinez
Alessandra rikta Elias Jennifer Ryland
Sierra Robbins
[Music]
Joanna P Sanchez mode Schmidt
Callen Seaton
[Applause]
Clara Tesla Clare Tebow Vladimir
Nicholas tell Ally Zuniga
jalla Trivedi Julie tumors Congrats
Amina Amina very a horse and Louise
burns Kelly Danica would Alan
ching-chong way
[Applause]
[Music]
now it's a contest good evening everyone
my name is Patricia ma soeur and it is
my great privilege and pleasure to
introduce the 2019 graduates of the MPA
in economic policy management or as we
affectionately call it and you just
heard Pepin our DME I do Rasika aht
urghan muhammad al-fatih dr abdullah al
shun see melissa ow
[Applause]
[Music]
man see multi
[Applause]
one Sebastian been talk for Luigi Bhutan
Samuel Carrasco Madrid so-called gia
[Applause]
Roman chakana peacock Mata Elena Delgado
Rojas Nicolas Espinosa
Aguila ciao whom Fong Tapia
Melvin canoe Aziz cocobolo
[Applause]
[Laughter]
Daniel Rocketeer Gaza Tanya wattage
[Applause]
[Music]
Alexis Linda
[Applause]
chilli
[Music]
[Applause]
Sarah Allen Muhammad Malik
Xavier Augustine Mackey era shota
Matsui Mariah
Yousef Muhammad your code Nakata any a
or chew
[Music]
master theorem Okamoto michelangelo
qualia unkept Shama
[Applause]
may you go so no kitaro sue me
lays on
Teodoro to feel marvelous Waya
Ritz key uni oriini jhana BEC Zordon off
congratulations everyone
[Applause]
it's my pleasure to introduce you to the
hard-working mission-driven
and scientifically literate 2019
graduates of the MPA in environmental
science and policy my name's Steve Cohen
I've had the honor of teaching these
students starting with Tamar aha Roni
[Applause]
miranda Alquist on Shu Chien Elaine
sunshine Angeles
[Applause]
Samuel Barnes Aurora Barone Caroline
Berman Shirley binder a Jana bode
[Applause]
leonard Brandis Simon
Stacia Carrington
Maria Chavez Zachary sure talk Emily
Clark
[Applause]
Luke cook Griffin
Stephanie Diaz you schongau Rosario
chief ray Erika Glen Emma guys leaner
[Applause]
Jackson goos a Lee Hagar Nicole hog pana
[Music]
[Applause]
Katelyn Harris Jacob Higden Hong Hong
[Music]
[Applause]
Felicia Horowitz fool and shoe long run
wah
[Music]
[Applause]
Eva I brought Julia Cup min Norton
Youssef cut Nick and Leone jaha Lange
[Music]
Anna Leibovitz and her children
[Applause]
Michelle Lou Catherine Louie Xiao Chen
Lu Lu Chen Lu Alyssa Neilson Rafael
Ortiz Evelyn Reese
[Applause]
Zachary Rosenblatt Mallory Rutigliano
[Music]
Lana Safranski sage salomina
Ashley Stein
Olivia Taylor Tavo Thomas true alkali
Sid to siani neha Villani Lindsey Weiner
Allison Walters Cornelia Wu Shu lien sha
Hansen's ooh
and last but not least yen you
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen is my great honor
to introduce the EMP a class of 2019 tez
Mena
Ahmed Alexis okagawa Pablo and gula
[Applause]
Shabnam sir Ozzie Aslam Noel Bannister
[Music]
khadijah belly
Alex born Yakov Elizabeth Boylan Augusto
Cabrera Rob aza Katherine Cashen
Rolando Castellanos Victoria Cerullo lo
que drah Xiao Han Liu Ling Chang holly
klein Kofi tank WA s Raja de Silva
[Music]
Alex Michael Dallin Ichi Fang
Olga get Sylar
[Applause]
[Music]
Bridget Gibbons Jamie go
[Applause]
Chow Kwok Jonathan Hansen Jessica and
hatch
[Applause]
Alicia Hill Motoko Momo Horry
see you in one
Thank You Madeleine
Casper Zack Michael Kwan
[Applause]
Amy she way Hwang Lee
stole the show
Betty Lin you Jolin you Rayna Messiah
[Applause]
John P McNown Kristen Moe bed
Chelsea molar
[Applause]
Katrina Niehaus Veronica poplu skaia
Judy Ramirez
Jordan Reisner giome ruse on
Dorinda silverstein Melinda and sledge
[Applause]
Susanna Montana Kagan Sean secant kit
Dinesh Soria Watchi Eugenia Terhune
Gracie max Terhune Cynthia Thompson
[Music]
[Applause]
Claire trunk Mary Waldorf
Shawn Wang mark Wyler Edna Wells handy
[Applause]
[Music]
Caroline Warnecke a be right Tian Jia
[Applause]
Singh LAN Chi si Dai you wan yang
Colleen
[Applause]
good evening I'm Colleen to me senior
associate dean at SEPA and it is my
great honor this evening to introduce
Cephas 2019 graduates of the master of
international affairs program
[Applause]
Mona Abu kar Osman
Farra a boost Aaliyah Karolina Acosta
Gutierrez Sarah Adams Mara off so anka a
gawky Nora Alka see me
[Applause]
[Music]
Andres Alegria
[Applause]
Raisa Ali moveth owari Kelsey Anderson
shamira and ghoulia Amanda on a male
Vanessa
Arellano benoni
[Applause]
[Music]
Jessica Nicole Arnold
Carmen Arroyo
[Applause]
here of azar
you Han Bao Laura M Beamer a leak
barbarian Amna buta Donna black
[Applause]
Molly blessing foetus Boley aqus Ross
and Beaulieu Jer day
Louis bourgeois Nisa Barry Lee run Brody
[Applause]
[Music]
Morris Breitbart Gabriel Brune Yin buoy
[Applause]
Jessica Burke
Lauren Butler Harold Karr Dainius Lima
[Applause]
Andreea casa verde miguel angel castaño
martin Klarich acanti Jeremy say bhalo
[Music]
mean Jin Qin chain Chen angel Joe hired
young Halle cha Priya
Choksey Michelle Sean
Jew Conrad
[Applause]
grace Garcia
Cushman Madhuri MoDOT
[Applause]
[Music]
Stephen denims alia Binta Thea whare
[Applause]
Clayton Dixon
pongee Taraka Johnny
[Music]
Julia Dre Hass Jin you do nee wa rahma
de tama tolya fe Miriam L at Wahby Iman
L Hossam bill GU know cheer aired in a
bot Muhannad ferrocene
Alexandra Feldhausen
[Applause]
Yong Yong Fung Christopher Franklin
[Music]
William gang wear Rouge yeah
[Applause]
Gloria gown
Gabriel James gardener
Muhammad Allah Ghanim Benjamin G&A Allah
Shiva Goldberg hunter Goldman valaria
Gomez Palacios
[Applause]
Carmen Gonzalez Romero Claire grillak
[Music]
[Applause]
Ana Guerrero
Tala heichal ed you are no rarey aria
car so no daniela heard
Joseph hopefully Tara Tiger Lara kick
[Applause]
hi Eun Hye Jung Hyung SK Darbar ooh just
a see on Alina hosen film run Ching how
Mallika Honus okati
one wrong Nicholas Herbert Hyman
[Applause]
Carranza a hottie rocky in time
[Music]
[Applause]
Rodrigo a new heir to a share ohm
Daria
yo Nova and Jacobs one John Chen G
Christian Johnson
[Applause]
Rasheeda Kaaba on Kagame
matthew micheal Kalyn jelly's Kartal
Brockman Karina Maria Coffman Gutierrez
[Music]
[Applause]
Zachary cos øz
[Music]
[Applause]
Tanna
chyme Jonathan Kennedy a mere who's on
Aisha
Abid Allah keep Juanita Ji Young Kim
Angie IO Yong Kim Catherine Kirk
a schwa thei KP c mon Kramer Kara
Michelle poop furberg Evans Cavell and
[Applause]
Johanna Kyle
and Larson
[Applause]
Justin Jung hooli island
Lee Jung Lee Sylvia
li rui Lee
[Applause]
Michael Lim when she leaned fill up lean
Cynthia Mui Chiu Fei Liu Leon Leon Louie
Jasper low Moira low Jade Luo shuuyu Lu
[Applause]
Patrick Maxwell
[Music]
Laura McHugh in Connor McGuire
[Applause]
Lara Mira swarn ollie Mitra Amanda
Posner sambal Muncey Camilla Nabi Ava I
[Applause]
naka she o dhivya Andra jog
Sophie no rare Caroline win amore
Normand Michelle nya
Kanna Papa Chris Titus Pavel padlet
Chuck Reina Poong Nicholas Perez Oscar
Perez Teresa de Lima Peru so
Alexander Alexander Patrick onna
Petrosian Claire picta Greta holo
[Applause]
Chintan Prakash SI phan tao
[Music]
Emma Raymond
[Applause]
Camilla Razavi Philip Wolfgang Renner
[Music]
she Toxie rhyme Oh Adam Robitaille I
sabayon
[Music]
Frances
[Applause]
Amanda Schmidt
Johannes Hendrik Schultz Isidora Mendes
sashes Chivas and Julia Warren sang
[Music]
yekaterina Camila Sharapova Jing sure
sure
[Applause]
Ivana small ANOVA
[Music]
Shawn song Jacob spring kocha one Shri
Monza
[Music]
Katie Sullivan Ryosuke Takahashi oka
Tanaka
[Applause]
[Music]
bori pet tank sirico Priscilla
Tacey mean Samantha Gene Taylor Brandon
Thompson
grace chandram Christian tri-c
Melanie sang santiana who say one
[Applause]
Alfredo Villavicencio Viera Xian Jun
Wang Shu way Wang Kingsley way Wang Yue
Tong win David Wicklund
[Applause]
and ton wider Roth Anthony Paul wins
Minh Neil's will lessen Osterberg will
Han Jie
[Music]
[Applause]
Jian XI Chi Ying Xiu Ning Zhi Shu Qing
rule Emma young
Laura Eunice
[Applause]
Fong you yeag or Zubrod Co seen on say
no moose abs 8 on shooting jong-seong
Shou
[Applause]
[Music]
gen-y eggshell
[Applause]
[Music]
yo Ron Joo
congratulations to the class of 2019
please rise for the recessional